oh please don't stop the music because
we love to see it
she claps on it too yup let's rewind
that back it's rihanna supporting her
man asap rocky at complex's complex con
in long beach california over the
weekend photographer rmn kalishien
posted this video on instagram there's
riri right next to the stage totally
lost in the moment wrapping the words to
her boyfriend's song peso alongside his
fans
i like to be in there a little bit you
know it's fun let's watch your back one
more time because that type of support
is the real deal
a source confirmed to et in 2020 that
the rapper and singer were officially an
item and in july a separate source told
et that the couple is together 24 7.
explaining quote they are so madly in
love they barely leave each other's side
the source added that quote asap is so
grateful for rihanna she's his biggest
cheerleader and he doesn't take her for
granted it's something he echoed while
talking to et at the premiere of his
documentary stockholm syndrome rihanna
is featured in it it was important
having that support in real life you
know and i think it just shows it will
reveal in the doc you know it's just how
it is in real life it's amazing and i'm
honestly truly blessed real you know
yeah we can tell in september the two
were all smiles as they made their red
carpet debut as a couple at the met gala
sharing their excitement with e.t
you guys are making a red carpet
official
speaking of being ready we know that
fans are eager for the bad girl herself
to release new music
y'all gonna have to wait navy i'm so
sorry but in the meantime she's
announced that limited edition vinyls of
her first eight albums are available for
pre-order on her website which will also
be accompanied by exclusive merchandise
i'm always working on music and as we
wait for r9 i guess we'll just have to
revel in riri and asap in love
[Music]